si tenemos un tubo de ensayo voy a
dibujarlo
si tenemos un tubo de ensayo y lo
llenamos de agua esperaríamos que la
superficie del agua fuera plana pero en
realidad la superficie del agua no es
plana sino más bien queda un poco más
arriba cuando está cerca del vidrio que
cuando está lejos del vidrio miren se
forma algo como esto pero como les
llamaremos a esto bueno a esto se le
conoce como menisco menisco y como en
este menisco el fluido está más arriba
cuando está cerca del contenedor podemos
decir que es un menisco cóncavo este es
un menisco cóncavo y tal vez pueden
decir oh sí éste es un menisco cóncavo
existirá un menisco convexo claro
también hay casos en los que hay
meniscos convexos por ejemplo supongamos
que tenemos el mismo tubo de ensayo pero
esta vez en lugar de llenarlo con agua
vamos a llenarlo con
pongamos mercurio si lo llenamos con
mercurio veremos un menisco como este
observen que se forma una elevación en
el centro lejos del contenedor
este es un menisco convexo convexo como
pueden ver es muy fácil identificar qué
es y cómo se llama por ejemplo a este es
un menisco cóncavo pero una pregunta muy
interesante es la de por qué se forma
bueno este menisco cóncavo se forma
porque una mayor parte del fluido es
atraído al contenedor en lugar de a sí
mismo ahora tal vez me digan espera un
momento hemos estado hablando de que el
agua tiene polaridad tiene una terminal
parcial negativa cada molécula tiene una
carga parcial negativa y una carga
parcial positiva en los hidrógenos voy a
escribir lo tenemos cargas parciales
positivas en los hidrógenos y eso
provoca que se forme un puente de
hidrógeno que es lo que le da al agua
sus propiedades
especiales pero ahora me dices que se
siente más atraído al vidrio que a sí
misma yo les digo si eso estoy diciendo
veamos por qué el agua se siente más
atraída al tubo de vidrio que a sí misma
miren las moléculas que hay en el vidrio
son un poco polares generalmente el
vidrio está hecho de dióxido de silicio
por cada átomo de silicio tenemos dos
átomos de oxígeno como lo que tenemos
aquí y resulta que la diferencia de
electrón negatividad entre el oxígeno y
el silicio es mayor a la diferencia de
electro negatividad que hay entre el
oxígeno y el hidrógeno porque el silicio
es menos electro negativo que el
hidrógeno y claro los oxígenos están más
que disponibles para acaparar los
electrones del silicio especialmente los
que están en los enlaces así que tenemos
una carga parcial positiva en el silicio
y cargas parciales negativas en los
oxígenos
al negativo y parcial positivo y ya se
imaginarán qué sucede en la superficie
todo esto es el agua esta parte
corresponde a las moléculas de agua y
esta parte todo lo que tenemos de este
lado son las moléculas de vidrio ok
entonces el agua se siente atraída a sí
misma por la formación de los puentes de
hidrógeno pero también hay un poco de
energía cinética todo se está moviendo
es un líquido pero de repente vamos a
ver digamos que esta molécula de agua
que hace un momento estaba por acá se
movió hacia acá tenía suficiente energía
cinética y al llegar aquí hizo contacto
con la superficie del vidrio y se pegó a
las moléculas del vidrio porque miren
esta parte es parcialmente positiva que
es la parte en donde están los
hidrógenos usar el color verde la
terminal parcial positiva los hidrógenos
sera
traída a la terminal parcial negativa
del vidrio los oxígenos y se pegarán de
hecho estas cargas parciales son más
fuertes que las que podemos encontrar en
el agua porque existe una diferencia de
electro negatividad mayor entre el
silicio y el oxígeno del vidrio que
entre el oxígeno y el hidrógeno del agua
entonces todo esto se está moviendo
constantemente tal vez hay otra molécula
de agua golpeando de este lado y en
algún momento se moverá hacia acá y se
pegará al vidrio a este fenómeno le
vamos a llamar adhesión adhesión debido
a la adhesión podemos observar que el
agua está un poco más arriba en estas
partes pero por otro lado si hablamos de
algo que se pega entre sí mismo entonces
a eso le llamaremos cohesión
eso es lo que hacen los puentes de
hidrógeno adentro del agua le llamaremos
cohesión por eso es que podemos ver un
menisco como este y bueno también
existen otras propiedades muy
interesantes respecto a la adhesión como
por ejemplo vamos a ver si tenemos un
contenedor con agua
y solo para que quede claro en el caso
del mercurio el mercurio se atrae más
entre sí mismo que con el tubo de vidrio
por eso vemos esta forma pero regresemos
al agua supongamos que tenemos una tina
muy grande y vamos a llenarla de agua ok
y supongamos que tomamos un tubo de
vidrio el material es muy importante
tiene que ser un material polar si es de
vidrio veremos un menisco y tal vez no
lo veríamos si tenemos un tubo de
plástico porque el plástico no tiene esa
polaridad bueno supongamos que tenemos
un tubo de vidrio muy muy delgado mucho
más delgado que un tubo de ensayo
si tenemos un tubo de vidrio muy delgado
y lo ponemos en el agua veremos algo muy
interesante observaríamos que el agua
desafía a la gravedad y empieza a subir
por el tubo eso es impresionante pero
por qué sucede bueno a este fenómeno se
le conoce como acción capilar también
llamada capilaridad la palabra capilar
se refiere a cualquier cosa que tenga
que ver con un tubo muy muy angosto como
por ejemplo la capilaridad de nuestro
sistema circulatorio nuestros capilares
son los vasos sanguíneos que son muy muy
delgados y hay acción capilar entonces
lo que vemos aquí es la acción capilar
que en realidad es simplemente una
adhesión muy intensa en la que más
moléculas de agua entran en contacto con
las moléculas polares del vidrio
imagínense que tenemos una pared de
vidrio aquí pero también tenemos una
pared de vidrio por acá esto no es un
dibujo a escala solo traten de imaginar
que quizá otra molécula de agua puede
brincar aquí y pegarse al vidrio con lo
que las moléculas seguirán empujando
hacia arriba pero mire si no tuviéramos
un contenedor polar o mejor dicho un
contenedor hidrofílico todo se caería
pero suponiendo que subió el agua de
alguna manera se quedara alguna molécula
vibrando por aquí y quizá atraiga a otra
molécula de agua y forme puentes de
hidrógeno así seguirán subiendo
esa es la acción capilar que es algo que
usamos todo el tiempo en nuestra vida
cotidiana simplemente porque los
capilares de nuestro cuerpo nos permiten
vivir pero por ejemplo supongamos que se
nos cayó un poco de agua así que
usaremos papel de cocina pero lo vamos a
poner en posición vertical
de esta forma veremos que el agua es
absorbida por el papel este tipo de
absorción también es una acción capilar
y el agua pasará por los pequeños
espacios de la toalla de cocina porque
es atraída por el papel